ready for the weekend Bryce are you
ready for the weekend Andy I think so
[Music]
[Applause]
Andy I kick off the weekend with you I
end them in love with you Bravo Khan
2022 blowout blowout we're still
standing uh I've been telling you all
weekend that we were gonna have news
about the Real Housewives of New York
City ladies and gentlemen here they are
big big announcement Roney is back Roney
yes can you run me through who these
women are and what we're gonna get out
of them and why they were the fit to
take the show into this next chapter we
were looking for a group of friends who
were actually uh connected and who are
vibrant living all over New York City uh
with interesting jobs and interesting
relationships and we found them with
this group we've got women in our group
is Brooklyn Tribeca the East Side
Chelsea the West Village so they're all
over town they're actually friends you
know we've got a fashion PR person we've
got a Somali supermodel we've got uh
Jenna Lyons who is known I mean she
revitalized the J.Crew brand she she is
speaks for herself uh we've got a um
Instagram influencer we've got so
there's all different types and I'm
really excited their energy and
excitement and humor it's going to be a
whole new Roney Dorinda crashed your ask
Andy panel
[Music]
not since joseon confronted me on the
air about why she was fired have I been
uh confronted like that by a housewife I
loved it and so listen it's an
interesting segue because yes we were
waiting to lock the cast of the new Roni
before we really got into who's going to
be on Legacy
we now Monday we're gonna start getting
into that now or press and play on
Monday we're pressing we're slowly
pressing play on Monday we're taking out
the pen and paper on Monday uh you also
teased at that ask Andy that Phaedra
more to come soon does that mean in
Dubai if me we've there are a couple
options in play for Phaedra and I
absolutely love her I'm a huge fan of
hers always have been it was so sad to
see her leave Atlanta and so I think
ultimate girls trip you know brought her
back into the fold it was great to see
her and and there are a couple ideas
that that we're kicking around with her
can you run through a little bit of the
housewife State of the Union Yes all
right we touched on Beverly Hills on
Friday we have Rena saying put me on
pause
we do what's what does the future look
like Karina well uh you know what we
kind of have those discussions that now
through the end of after when the
reunions air so uh you know everybody's
I think the key to the success of this
thing that it's been going 16 years is
that we take people out we put people in
and we try to keep it fresh in terms of
specifics of Rena and anyone else I mean
I think everything's on the table but
nothing to announce about that right now
we didn't talk about Diana okay Diana
checks every box I could think of you
would want of a housewife yes the
audience did not seem to take her okay
why do you think that happened I think
that she you know she very
um confidently said that she didn't
watch the show before she came on I
think that was maybe a situation where
it would have she didn't know
to watch the show uh because I think
when it started airing also it would
have she would have understood what was
it was going to be Kathy Hilton said
she's not coming back if we're in it's
back when the housewives did she make
that delineation yeah well she said if
it's this cast and that kind of goes
down to one person does it not
um when housewives make those sort of
ultimatums what do you make of that I
mean listen it's been done before it
doesn't always work for that person I
mean listen you know we have to see who
wants to come back we have to see what
we're gonna do there's there are a lot
of questions still to be answered and so
you know I'm not surprised that she had
that opinion and you know I'm sure there
are other people in the group who don't
want to come back if other people in the
group are coming back so that's usually
the place we're at right about now right
yes and two more episodes of reunion to
watch yes and then decisions will be
made yes exactly you are the biggest
bully in Hollywood and everyone knows it
Atlanta yes Sheree wants Kim Zolciak
back she wants OG's back okay Kim if you
are watching you need to come hang out
with me and the girls I would love to
have you back do you think we will see
returns anytime soon Porsche anytime
soon I mean listen the door's open for
Porsche
um and Kim I don't know that Kim would
want to come back to be honest with you
you know I always love Kim and I always
love an OG coming back yeah so yeah so
doors open yeah Dubai cameras are not up
on season two yet yes but are we getting
a season two I hope so uh I think we
have a lot to grow on
Ayan was telling me
um how she and Caroline Stanberry have
really mended fences and I think that
the two of them could wind up being a
great Duo actually and I would look
forward to seeing them together I think
they would be a lot of fun together I
think they could run the world I do too
I do too
um people really thought a Dallas
announcement was coming out of bravocon
yeah I don't know is it like kind of on
the back burner I think it's on the way
back burner yeah I mean listen Miami was
on the way back burner for many years
eight years yeah I mean the thing is
Miami was always we always had the
audience was always so passionate it was
the question that I got all the time
when you were bringing back Miami and
Miami is such a perfect housewife City
and I think you will see this season on
Miami it's just it's phenomenal it's a
great season it's very dramatic it's
really funny there are some shifting
alliances and
um it's there's a lot for viewers to
sink their teeth into yeah we were
gifted that trailer oh yeah come on come
on give it to me I'm done talking to you
and just the ultimate girls trip three
trailer which looks like it puts one and
two to shame which is hard to do it's
true
listen these girls trips are really
social experiments so you never know how
they're gonna go this one was just wild
in so many directions I don't I don't
think people are ready for it to be
honest I mean you thought Bluestone
Manor was wild
get ready for Thailand yeah are we ready
for Jersey
yeah Jersey is excellent and we've got
some new blood it feels like the Jersey
we love and obviously there's you know
some major shifts in the Teresa Melissa
Joe Gorga
relationship but we've got some some new
women in the mix who really energized
the show but they feel perfectly Jersey
and they fit in the group really well
it's been very mixed between the judices
and the gorgas and the rules now this
weekend of like where this thing goes
from here do you have any idea where it
can go from here
I don't think it's gonna going anywhere
good anytime soon unfortunately would it
be like one of them is no longer a
housewife territory oh where that's
going oh well that's I mean that's a
conversation for like a year from now
right we gotta get through the season
the wedding and the reunion we have a
full season ready to go we have a
reunion we haven't done I mean a lot can
happen uh Salt Lake City yes is there a
plan in place to make sure we get Jen
and a reunion seat before
you know she goes to camp there's not
much to say about that except that I
certainly have a lot of questions for
her and I would love to ask them and
have the opportunity to do so and I hope
that we can figure that out uh she
popped up in New York this weekend she
sure did she did and she said she was
invited
she did say that
where do you think that show goes if Jen
is not part of the picture is it bring
Mary Cosby back
um I think it is again we have a whole
season to get through we have a reunion
we're only three episodes in so let us
get through this and
um we'll see where we go
people think you control all of Bravo I
do not
does that get to you at all are you just
like it comes with the territory face of
the network I think it comes with the
territory but also I mean I'm getting
tweets about you know
like the bathroom situation at the
Javits Center I'm like you do realize
that I'm not doing everything here right
so um I want everyone to be happy listen
if they need me to be the person that
they say thank you or they want to punch
here I am but like the girl who was
pitching to uh be the party planner for
bravocon next year you're not the guy
I'm not the guy yes I'm not the guy
foreign
[Music]